a tense standoff between protesters and
Liberian security forces after
demonstrators tried to march to the
office of the president a move the
police have been asked to stop so the
demonstrators broke into a
song-and-dance asking the president to
quit office there was also a small group
of government supporters but the police
quickly stepped in to disperse them
because they had no permit to hold a
counter protest organizers were hoping
for a large anti-government gathering
but the massive police presence proved
an effective deterrent the right to
protect peacefully you cannot intimidate
them the message that have been sent
today that even if his funeral I Brenda
have gathered and sent a message and
what is the message is anything that is
you have people who are disenchanted
people who are not satisfied based on
the way governance is be handled honor
that we are administration the crowds of
this demonstration were nowhere near the
numbers seen in June 2019 but their
message remains the same they want an
end to what they call rampant corruption
to stop economic decline and for the
president to publicly declare his asset
although the Constitution did not make
it mandatory for him to do so many
librarians are disappointed that the
elected representatives failed to stand
up to the President to stop the excesses
they are protesting against an opinion
shared by some parliamentarians
members of the lesson engine think act
as though the serve at the pleasure of
the President against the aspiration in
terms of the people the government for
its part says it has resolved many of
the grievances of the protesters and
blames agitators for stirring up trouble
President George Weah may have survived
a third major protest of his two-year
old government what's not clear is if
protesters will once again take to the
streets as promised if the government
fails to meet their demands how many
trees al Jazeera Monrovia